today's guest is professor richard
borchardt
of uc berkeley richard is one of the
brightest people if not the brightest
person that i've been lucky to speak to
on this channel he's a fields medalist
and a fields medal is essentially the
nobel prize equivalent of mathematics
he was awarded this medal due to him
proving a speculative assertion at the
time
put forward by conway that the that
there's a deep connection between the
monster group
and the j function which is a simple or
one of the simplest modular forms
this is called the monstrous moonshine
conjecture and it was proven by
professor borchards in the early 1990s
when he was in his early 30s
the monster group is the largest of all
the sporadic simple groups
and its order is of the size of pretty
much all the atoms
that comprise the earth so around 10 to
the 53 if i'm not mistaken orchard also
runs a wonderful youtube channel
which the link is in the description
it's essentially teaching graduate
mathematics
over the next few months i'll be asking
mathematicians and physicists about how
they think and how they study
because if you're watching this you're
likely a sagacious individual
who knows the importance of self-study
this is because it's often more
important to know how to think about a
problem
rather than exactly how to solve this
particular problem because the former
generalizes to more problems and more
solutions
if you'd like to see more conversations
like this then please consider
supporting at
patreon.com kurtjmungle right now
there's the goal of hosting multiple
intellectuals on
simultaneously almost like theomaki so
that they can battle it out in real time
the first will be bernardo castro and
donald hoffman and jonathan verveicky
simultaneously if i'm lucky enough to
reach
around 50 patrons i'll be able to host
this conversation thank you so much to
all my current patrons
i hope you enjoy part of this was filmed
as a live stream so if it looks like i'm
reading
i am i'm most likely reading an audience
question enjoy
first of all why don't you tell the
audience a little bit about yourself
your interest what field of math you
study
um math professor working mania and
algebra number theory
um i did some stuff on monstrous
moonshine about 20 or 30 years ago and
have been
struggling to do something similar ever
since
similar as in you can't announce it or
you can well um
i i feel like one of these people
you know that said that the worst thing
that can happen to a musician is they
have a big hit
early in their career because they spend
the rest of their time trying to
equal that and i feel i'm in sort of
that position that i did
monstrous moonshine when i was young and
i've been
never managed to do anything similar
since how did you get interested in
mathematics
um i've always been as long as i can
remember i mean i i think someone was
asking me this question why did i decide
to become a mathematician i never did
decide i just
was a mathematician right you equated it
to being a dolphin or a dolphin deciding
something like that yeah how did you
become interested in the particular
field that you're interested in
oh moonshine that that was sort of by
accident
um i i went to a talk by john conway as
an undergraduate
once you know he he
he would sometimes give undergraduate
talks and he mentioned this
it was about finite simple groups which
either sort of vague idea of what they
were and he said well there was this
monster group with this
dimension living in dimension one nine
six
eight eight three and you also mentioned
this is the same as the coefficient of
the elliptic modular function i was just
you know just completely blown away by
this it was just
you know that these were two
areas of mathematics that had absolutely
nothing to do with each other there was
this bizarre coincidence going on
so so that's how i got interested in it
do you find that there's some connection
between
unifying different fields in math and
unifying different fields in physics
because as you know unification happens
frequently in physics but it seems to
also happen in math
there's a sort of vague analogy i mean
one of the things i've discovered in
math is you really want to know
little bits of lots of different areas
because every now and then you find some
bizarre connection between two
apparently different areas
and i would guess the same is sort of
true in physics for instance
you know maxwell unified light and
electromagnetism
and that there were two apparently
completely different areas of physics
but maxwell happened to know about both
of them so he was able to unify them
i guess gravitational quantum field
theory is another very topical example
that they you know general relativity
looks quite different from
quantum mechanics and it's a big problem
trying to
connect them what do your average days
look like
do you wake up at a particular time do
you remember i wake up at random times
and frankly
most of my days spent procrastinating
about various things i ought to be doing
um i mean supposed to be doing
mathematics research but mathematics
research consists mainly of trying to do
things that don't work
and what do you procrastinate with what
are your advices
oh i can procrastinate by
making youtube videos on mathematics or
something like that
do you play any video games or do you go
for walks do you have pets or kids
i go for walks i used to have chickens
but they they all died a few years ago
how much time do you spend studying
versus
well let's say you're doing research
some of the research is studying
some of the research is just writing
some of it is thinking some of it is
collaborating
what does that look like for you and how
much time do you get to spend in each
let's say on a weekly basis
yeah um i knew an accountant once who
said they had to spend
for every 15 minutes of the day they had
to write down what they were doing
and i've never done anything like that
and i never dared to because if i did
i would probably be horrified at what i
was wasting my time on all the time
um i i just don't know
um i probably spend far less time doing
useful stuff than i like to imagine
so you don't feel like you manage your
time well it's dreadful at it
i'm poorly organized and have atrocious
time management
skills let's say that you had an ideal
day
in terms of process so not in terms of
outcome because your ideal day may be
solve the riemann hypothesis in the
morning move on to so-and-so and solve
it so forget about that
process that is spend four hours
writing spend two hours answering email
i don't know whose ideal day would be
emails i can't
what would your idea look like i i can't
spend four hours a day
working on anything i i just get too
fidgety and impatient
um i mean ideal day would be if i was
able to focus
on something that well um yes
i mean sometimes in the past when
mathematics when research was going well
i could spend you know
12 or 16 hours a day working on a
calculation
straight or with breaks well i'd have
lunch
occasionally and things like that but
yeah yeah it was
when i was younger i really was able to
spend many hours straight working on
something
now is that a function of age that
decline or is it because of interest
i don't know probably
just getting less energetic as you get
older or something
are you more creative now than you were
when you were younger i don't seem to be
i mean when i was in my 20s and 30s i
was getting all these ideas and they all
worked and
these days i'm getting loads and loads
of ideas and they all fail
can you give an example of what an idea
that worked for an idea that failed
recently let's say in the past two
months past two months
um well
nothing very easy to explain i mean
they're the
they're all rather technical ideas i
mean i mean that's fine
i mean i i can tell you i mean i was
trying to find an extension of the smith
minkowski ziggler formula to give an
exact number for class numbers rather
than a
weighted sum which probably means
absolutely nothing to most people
you'll find that much like the audience
of yours the audience of this channel
they comprise extremely bright people
some post docs some
even professors so don't worry if you
feel like you're going above someone's
head
it seems like one of the appeals of this
podcast is the fact that we do go into
some technicalities unlike other
podcasts which tend to stay at a fluffy
or
cosmetic level well i can go into
technicalities if you want but i suspect
your audience is going to plummet
but whatever what do you feel like is
your greatest
strength and your greatest weakness
greatest strength
i'm really obstinate um that i can
keep working on a problem for i can keep
coming back to it
year after year and sometimes you know
when you come back to a problem for the
tenth
time you finally make some progress on
it
um weakness over too many to think of
um as i said i've got lousy time
management and work skills
i don't collaborate with people nearly
as much as i ought to
you know most of the top mathematicians
have this fantastic
network of talking to other good
mathematicians and
i'd i do far too little of that why is
that
um poor social socials i guess social
anxiety or just poor social skills or
disagreeableness
um just just not very good at
interacting with people
and i never quite figured out how to do
it
i was watching one of your q and a's and
someone said what's or who is the nicest
mathematician and you said
they're all pretty much nice so then if
they're all pretty much nice that to me
implies that you get along with them
unless you're not being nice in return
so why is it that you don't get along
with them i do get along with them just
fine it's just kind of stressful
interacting with people so i
just just tend to not do it unless i
have to
what are the advantages of that see
there's the soul mathematician or the
soul physicist who in isolation comes up
with the brilliant idea
i believe max planck was a proponent of
that
but then all there are obviously others
well people have different
styles i mean there are some people like
a tear and say who are fantastic at
collaboration
and there are other people i think i
mean perilman is an obvious example he
he just
went off by himself didn't talk to
anybody else
work for 10 or 20 years and solve this
absolutely fantastic problem i mean that
that's that's the sort of
idea of what that that's a sort of one
ideal of mathematics research you you
you just
solve a problem by yourself by brute
force but it's
actually it's very rare that that
happens nearly all mathematics is
done very collaboratively these days are
there any advantages to studying math
later in life so for example starting in
your 20s or
starting in your 30s or even 40s we can
take those as three different questions
yeah i haven't heard of any
mathematicians who started in their 30s
or 40s there'd been a
a few really good mathematicians who
started in their 20s i mean i think ed
whitman was
doing history as an undergraduate or
something and only started taking math
seriously in his twenties
so i mean it might be possible i just
don't know of any cases i mean it may be
something like learning languages you
if you learn languages when you're young
you're much much better
than if you start when you're older did
you enjoy your graduate studies more
than your undergrad
um they were both fun i mean
um i wouldn't say either
i enjoyed either more than the other
when i was watching one of your talks
you
mentioned quite a few times and probably
even in some of
your non-q a videos you mentioned that
interest matters so if you're gonna pick
a problem pick one that you're terribly
interested in
because over the long run you'll be
faced with
you'll be set with problems and so on
and it had me wondering
did you either voluntarily like force
yourself
or it was forced upon you have to study
some piece of math that you
absolutely hated and now you abhor
studying whatever you're not interested
in
well i i've never actually bothered
studying math i didn't like
i mean i don't remember anybody past
high school telling me to
study math that i didn't want to i mean
at
university you can very much pick what
just
what you want to study i mean
high school yes i i was forced to study
various bits of applied math that i
can no longer stand often solving
mathematical problems requires a certain
state of mind
do you find yourself going through
periods where you feel like
your mind is not creative enough not
focused enough and how do you
solve that yeah of course well you just
have to go off and do something
else so um
there are several things you can do for
this i mean john conway told me that
that what he he did is he always had a
sort of background calculation so he'd
be calculating tables of knots or
tables of lattices or something you can
you you can do that even if you're not
feeling inspired and
i think richard feynman had this idea
that you would always do teaching as a
sort of background
thing and the the point in both cases is
so that you have
something where you can see that you're
making progress because the i mean the
trouble with research is most of the
time you're you're working hard and
making no progress at all and this is
psychologically kind of a bit depressing
so you need to have something something
else you can do where you can actually
make visible progress on it
what's the longest lull or the longest
involuntary cognitive hiatus you've
experienced
well i'd say um hard to say i mean it
might be now um i've been working on a
problem for
several years and i
i i don't know what the progress is
because you know 20 times i think i've
solved it and got really excited
and and then i start to write a top and
geez there's this huge hole i somehow
overlooked so i go back to being
depressed for a bit and
and so it keeps on switching backwards
and forwards between thinking i solved
and thinking i haven't and i
you know i i sometimes think that that
sooner or later i'm going to be
get so senile that i can't actually
figure out what's wrong with my solution
and then i can publish it and
you know you know the the the the this
is what this is actually
unfortunately what happens to some
mathematicians when they get old
they sort of lose this capacity to see
what's wrong with what they're doing
you mentioned depression i don't know if
you just meant that as a throwaway
comment but do you feel like
you're characterized by depression or
are you just using that in the informal
sense
i i don't feel i've ever had anything
i'd call depression i mean
of course you go through phases when
you're feeling a little bit
less happy than usual um actually i i
don't know i mean i
me maybe i'm just not very good at
spotting symptoms of depression i
remember seeing a poster once of saying
you know
um look out for these typical symptoms
of depression i
remember being really unimpressed by
that because i was thinking that was
sort of
my normal state as a graduate student i
didn't count that as being depressed so
maybe i just don't recognize depression
someone asked
what's your iq and do you have any
methods of increasing iq
i've no idea what my iq is and
as far as i know the only method of
increasing iq is to go back in time
because your iq steadily decreases as
you get older
have you taken any nootropics or
supplements to try and either stave off
cognitive deterioration or to improve
your cognitive state
no idea besides caffeine i don't take
caffeine and i don't know what a new
tropic is and i stay well clear of
anything that's remotely mind-altering
you don't drink coffee
i don't drink coffee no tea you're
british
no tea well i i drink tea out of
politeness
if someone puts it in front of me do you
find that depression is higher in
mathematicians than in the general
population
um way outside my expertise i've no idea
what the incidence of depression is in
either the general population or
mathematicians i've i've never noticed
mathematicians being particularly
depressed but i'm
so clueless i probably wouldn't notice
even if they were
i mean the reason is that you mentioned
you read the signs of depression one
time on a bus ad or somewhere
and you thought oh that's my entire
department
well yeah but i mean i
i i it's it's not like i'm qualified to
actually
diagnose people with depression or not
it was just
you know you you go through periods
where you you know depression is
you know they have things like you go
through periods when you're
getting nowhere feel you're getting
nowhere and so on and that that's just
normal for research if you're
researching anything serious
what's your creative process like is it
different depending on the problem or do
you have a general framework
um a lot of randomness in it um
you you just i mean i think what's the
creative process like it's sort of like
um you know imagine you're on one of
these huge
um garbage dumps that you you know you
sometimes see in countries there are
these garbage dumps of people
picking over them looking for something
interesting and research is a bit like
that you're
wandering around this area looking out
for
something that somebody else has
overlooked and
nearly all the time you don't find
anything because most areas in math
research have been
pretty well picked over by everybody so
you're continually trying out new things
and 99 of the time the new thing you've
tried out
either doesn't work or if you work on it
and discover that someone's already
thought of it
creative process is just trying to
generate enormous numbers of
ideas and throwing nearly all of them
away
actually i've heard the same something
like this is actually supposedly true in
business that i think um
what is it the guy who does the gilbert
cartoons was saying somewhere you know
he had tried
30 ideas for making money and and 27 of
them
failed or something like that right
scott adams
yeah so he you just keep on generating
new ideas and discard the ones that
don't work
do you find you think more geometrically
or algebraically or you think in words
or are you thinking concepts
uh i i tried to wonder about that and
it's amazingly difficult to actually
figure out what's going on in your own
brain
um um it's
it's something that's very difficult to
describe i seem to have sort of
some sort of algorithms built into the
brain and i sort of know how they're
going to work
and i just don't know how to describe
this i mean
there's a bit of geometric
um imagination going on in there
and there's a bit of algebraic
manipulation but i don't know how the
algebraic manipulation works because i'm
doing things with formulas that are
far too complicated for me to actually
visualize i mean i
i can't visualize the formula itself in
my mind but somehow
i still know what it's doing and i've
i've no idea how this works
um actually the mathematician jacques
adamar once
wrote for a lot of mathematicians asking
them to describe how they thought um
and i the problem is it's so long ago
since i looked at this that i can't
remember what he what conclusions he
came to but
um there have been some attempts by
mathematicians to research this question
i was reading penrose's emperor's new
mind and
for anybody who is a mathematician or
physicist that wants to read that book
just read the last third
it was a slug to get through it was
quite an ordeal to get through the first
bit because it's so much
retreading of similar ground and the
last third is actually where it's
interesting
but in the last third he talks about
when he was in high school
he's noticed that he thought differently
than his peers and then
when he got to university he thought
okay great i'll be around other
mathematicians and physicists so
we'll think alike but then he found that
there is even more a diversity in the
in terms of how people think what i'm
wondering is
have you encountered that yeah i i
noticed this too that
that has sort of gradually dawned on me
that lots of people
learn or think in completely different
ways i mean one example is lectures i
mean i i've always found
lectures if i go to a lecture i fall
asleep after 10 minutes i just can't
stay awake and i do all my learning from
books and
i sort of assumed everyone was like this
but no an
awful lot of people do most their
learning from lectures and just
hardly open the textbook so so there are
very different styles
and again some people obviously
very powerful geometric intuition
and other people have some sort of very
good intuition about something abstract
like
set theory and a very little geometric
intuition and so on
when you work do you have to have
uninterrupted bouts of
time exclusive to yourself so what i
mean is
there's this concept called deep work
and i'm wondering if you
instituted that where you tell i don't
know if you're married are you married
first of all yeah
okay so dude tell your wife don't bother
me for four hours because i am
working or do you just you start working
and then she interrupts you that's okay
because that's your process
well yeah i mean if i get interrupted
which happens quite regularly i just
pick it up later um
it just varies i mean i think uh you
have to be a bit like jane austen i just
sort of remember she
she wrote her novels in you know
whenever she could snatch 15 minutes
from her social life or something like
that so you
you you you get so you can work in
whatever spare time you have
do you read any non-mathematical books
yeah i read plenty of novels and things
and
books about physics and general interest
science books and so on what would be an
example of one that you particularly
liked besides
lord of the rings well there's
i don't know game of thrones and um
hang on um
fairly eclectic reading i mean i like
agatha christie novels or um
my mind is blanking out or terry
pratchett or
any any light reading i mean i don't go
around reading sort of
the sort of deep literature that people
in in english literature classes write
essays about
and i've got a copy of finnegan's wake
up stairs and
you know you can open it random page and
i can't understand a single sentence
mandalore here wants to know if you've
read or heard of jordan peterson and
what you think of him or his work jordan
peterson yeah i i've got one of his
books about
um had the word 12 in it i seem to
remember
um the most important part just that
number yeah yeah
and i i sort of read it but must admit i
can't remember an awful lot about it
anymore
do you find that you read slow when it's
a non-mathematical book or even when
it's a mathematical book
uh i read math books slowly other books
fairly fast
i mean math books very slowly
and it takes a long time to absorb
what's in it if it's anything new
okay i'm going to take a question from
the audience here oh okay
prime time durkheim says has he
experienced any sort of moments of
madness or psychological aberration
being someone who has a lifelong habit
of working in high math in isolation
nothing that i've noticed but i mean if
maybe i'm mad and
so mad that i don't notice i'm mad who
knows
maybe doing mathematics obsessively is
is itself a mad thing to do
socolo is stan 96 says
he said he avoids anything that is mind
altering so do you also avoid certain
foods
or do you optimize your diet in general
do you do intermittent fasting
um i tried intermittent fasting for
about three or four hours once
i don't think that counts yeah well
um yeah that's infinitesimal fasting
well yeah i mean i think i tried it for
a day or two and it didn't seem to make
much difference i gave up
no i i i don't have any particular food
habits
and it's mostly vegetarian partly for
health reasons but other than that
nothing interesting how is it that you
go about
learning a new math and either learning
from a new field or
learning math in general it's very slow
you have to
i mean as i said i i learned by reading
so
what you have to do is to well i learned
by reading and by calculating examples
and it's a very long slow process
learning anything i mean
um generally you know try reading about
it in a dozen different books
working out lots of examples and you
know the first
half dozen times i try and learn it i
just forget it again
um i mean i i i suspect there are a lot
of other good mathematicians who are
much more efficient at learning things i
mean i i get the impression there are
some people who can learn things just by
reading about it once but
i've never been able to do that it's
kind of like learning
you know the way people learn languages
you you learn a language by
you you have to do a lot of repetition
of basic stuff before it sinks in
at least for most people and again there
are some people who seem to be able to
learn 10
or 20 languages i've no idea how they do
it
in one of your q as you mentioned when
someone asks you about setbacks and
difficulties what do you do about them
you said
often you just ignore them because
you'll be surprised how many problems
disappear yeah yeah yeah this is my
fundamental problem solving technique
um especially when when someone else
comes up with a problem for me to do i
sort of figure well if it was really
important they would have done it so i
can just ignore it
do you mind giving a specific example of
a problem you ignored and then it was
solved
um or that you'd realize you didn't even
have to solve it to begin with
um
i actually find that's that's sort of
true of a surprising number of problems
actually in math research if i if i
don't try and understand a problem and
just sort of
don't try and work hard in it and just
sort of put it aside
that then you find a month or two later
you suddenly
realize it's kind of obvious what you
ought to be doing i mean
maybe it's just my subconscious is
working on it or something i don't
really know
i mean since it's subconscious i don't
know what's going on in there
akash says what advice does he have for
someone in their mid-20s to learn math
and physics
i work in law and i'm interested in
physics i would like to get
a better understanding of physics now i
know fermat and kaylee i believe were
lawyers
in their mid-20s when they started
physics sorry yeah and they started
math i mean yeah sure as you point out
though that there are a couple of
rather prominent examples of lawyers who
end up being really rather good at math
um advice i'd just say follow whatever
you're interested in
um i mean and what one thing
you can do for example is you just go
into a math library and just
browse at random you know you can pick
out books at random look at the first
few pages see if it's interesting and
if it's interesting you could go deeper
into it um
so i think this is an example of what i
was saying of
generating random ideas how do you do it
well
one way is just to pick out books at
random in a math library and see what
they say
and again you know 90 or 99
of the time there won't be anything
interesting there but every now and then
you
you you run into run into something
really good
what is it about infinity categories
that you find confounding or troublesome
the definition to start off with i mean
it's it's one of these definitions
i i must have read it half a dozen times
and
half an hour later i just totally forgot
what the definition is
it just it just doesn't seem to stick in
my mind at all i mean
most things you know i have to read them
you know half a dozen times before they
stick infinity categories
i i don't know half a dozen times
there's nowhere near enough
have you read any of emily riehl's work
on infinity categories
uh no no i don't know any of that okay
does he somehow systematically order his
knowledge mathematical or other
in something like a tree of knowledge
does he explicitly memorize theorems or
proof
to make use of them more easily
absolutely not i i'm
as i said i'm really disorganized um
i'd i've never bothered trying to learn
the proof of a theorem or memorize the
theorem
um i just sort of
re-read them several times so i probably
eventually do sort of know the proofs
but i never made a conscious effort to
memorize the proofs
um what i do try and do is instead of
memorizing a proof so i can write it out
word for word
um which is useless i mean a photocopier
can do that
um you somehow want to internalize the
ideas behind
the essential ideas in a proof and
it's sort of very hard to explain
exactly what this is i mean you somehow
want to
know the theorem well enough that you
can actually use the ideas for something
else which of course a photocopier can't
do
and what's going on in my mind when this
is going on i just no idea
do you find that you're happy with your
life yeah sure
um maybe i'm just too dumb to notice i
shouldn't be happy but yeah yeah i'm
generally happy
are you increasingly sol that is with
time you find it more meaningful
about the same not something i pay a lot
of attention to but
what are the most meaningful aspects of
your life doing math mainly
relationships well i've
i've got two kids and i'm married yeah
do you find the relationship with your
kids to be more meaningful than the
mathematics
it's different i mean and i'm not sure
you can really compare them they're
quite different sorts of relationships
okay how about this all the major math
theorems that you want
solved are solved and you have
as much money as you like what do you do
with your time sleep i don't know
um i've no idea um
i mean i spent all my life basically my
spare time has been spent thinking about
mathematics if there was no mathematics
left to do i
really don't know um
it's sort of like
maybe just read math for fun or
something i mean it's it's
still quite i mean even if you're not
actually doing research it's still quite
interesting just reading other people's
theorems and their research
so it would be a bit like me asking a
dolphin what if you weren't a dolphin
anymore and it can't conceptualize it
yeah yeah i mean it's it's just
the question doesn't actually mean very
much what was it like to win the fields
medal
um rather an anti-climax um
yeah um
[Music]
i mean it didn't really mean very much i
mean it was just a sort of
rather embarrassing ceremony where where
i when i sort of froze as far as i
remember
and they they you know actually proving
proving the theorems is fun you feel
very excited when you've done that
but but you know getting a medal or
something for it is just
just sort of nothing the the only
advantage of it
is is as you stop is you stop worrying
about getting these
these things when you realize how
unimportant they are
when you talked about math you mentioned
that it was it's meaningful to you maybe
one of the most meaningful if not the
most meaningful aspect of your life so
what is it
particularly about math that you find
meaningful
it's understanding it's part of
understanding how the universe
works you know there are all these
fundamental questions like why does the
universe exist and what are the
fundamental laws of physics
and mathematics is part of that um
so um whenever you're doing mathematics
you sort of
it every piece of mathematics is helping
you a little bit to understand how the
universe works maybe not very much
but um you know the universe as far as
we can tell from
physics the universe is running mainly
on mathematics although we
haven't yet quite figured out the exact
mathematics behind
it does that mean that you have the
sense that when you're
performing math you're engaged in an act
of discovery rather than invention
oh very much so um mathematics is yeah
the
there's this question about it do you
invent or discover math and i'd say it's
entirely discovered not invented well
there are one or two areas i won't
mention where i would say it's invented
and
totally useless but but almost all
mathematics it's
you're discovering something that's
already there so a classical example of
this is the
monster sporadic simple group and this
this has always
really amazed me because you know the
axioms for a finite simple
group are so trivial you you can write
them out in one line and they're very
true they're natural and then the
monster simple group is
somehow hidden in this single line so
we've got this monster simple group with
what 10 to the 54 elements and this
fantastically intricate structure
somehow hiding in this trivial one-line
definition
and a lot of the best mathematics is
like that you
you you know you you
you've got some sort of box that looks
just like a plain small
box without anything figuring it out and
you open it up and somehow there's this
massive diamond inside it with no
indication on the outside of the box
there's anything
like that in it what is it about the
monster group
or the monster the sporadic monster
group that you find fascinating because
to an outsider so let's say someone
who's not interested in math
to say that it's interesting is almost
as arbitrary as saying
why are there six platonic solids or why
does the number 1740 exist
yeah um because we don't understand why
the monster exists
i mean you know so there's this
classification of the finite simple
groups
and the classification says well there
are these infinite families
and okay infinite families of things are
kind of uninteresting and
well okay they're not uninteresting but
most mathematicians find them very
interesting but
um finding an infinite family of things
isn't too surprising but but the
classification says there are these
infinite families like alternating
groups and then there
are 26 others left over which
there's no obvious reason why they
should exist and the infinite families
you can sort of think of a reason why
they exist i mean you know they're
they're
general linear groups and they exist
because they're symmetries of vector
spaces
it's a very natural explanation and then
you have these sporadic simple groups
exist and they exist because
well nobody really has any idea why they
exist there's
there's no explanation for them beyond
going through
you know 10 000 pages of the
classification
um so this this may be one of these
unanswerable questions like you know
what i mentioned is why does the
universe exist um
i mean maybe it just doesn't have an
answer
what would an answer look like i this is
the problem i just cannot imagine
how you could even answer the question
why does the universe exist i mean
imagine an answer that would satisfy you
as to why the monster group exists what
would that even look like
um one one thing might be that
you know that there's some very natural
class of geometric objects
whose symmetries are the
um sporadic simple groups and people
have been searching for this for
decades and no one has ever found any
plausible candidates
so um
i mean for instance the infinite
families of groups there is a sort of
natural answer they
that they all act that the the they
all have these structures called bn
pairs
and this sort of gives an explanation of
them
that there's a uniform construction of
all the
spread it of all these simple groups
that aren't sporadic you know there's
sort of one construction that works for
all of them you just
twiddle a few parameters and you you get
out all of them but for the spreadings
there's nothing like that
what is it about quantum field theory
that you find difficult
um in our email exchange you mentioned
that it gives you a headache
yeah i think the problem is that
mathematicians are trained that
everything should be really precisely
defined
and you you shouldn't go into the next
step before you've completely understood
all the previous steps
and quantum field theory just isn't like
that things just
aren't precisely defined and if you try
and really find out what the definition
is you find there's nothing there and it
just doesn't make sense
um so do you mind giving an example yeah
sure if if you look at fiment diagrams
for example there are
um that they give you a sort of
asymptotic expansion of something like a
scattering coefficient or whatever
so it's a well-defined asymptotic
expansion
you can sort of make sense of that and
it's an asymptotic expansion of
and at that point you suddenly get stuck
um
no one has actually figured out what
it's an asymptotic expansion of
so in some sense it doesn't really make
sense
and what is even more annoying is it i
mean if it didn't make sense i could
cope with that
the trouble is that it doesn't make
sense and it gives answers that you can
check in experiments and this is
really annoying because you know
theoretically it doesn't make sense but
experimentally it does so there's this
horrible conflict
um um so
and so so i mean in some sense the
fundamental problem of
quantum field theory is to give a
rigorous definition of it there still
isn't one
well people have given rigorous
definitions the trouble is
the the the quantum field theories that
people actually use
in the standard model don't fit these
rigorous definitions or at least no one
has managed to prove that they do
and so this has been an open problem for
maybe 90 years or so do you have any
thoughts on the existence of free will
do you think you have free will and if
not then why not if so why so
how are you defining it i thought about
this a bit and what i
eventually came to the conclusion was
that i didn't even know how to define
what free will
was so if you can't define something
precisely it makes it very hard to
discuss
in fact this this is a big problem with
an awful lot of philosophical questions
if you look at them close enough you
discover the terms in them are simply
not well defined enough to talk about
so can you even define free will can you
talk about it not as a mathematician but
let's say as a regular person about what
free will
about free will now what you're saying
is that there's the slippery definition
but so
there is also a slippery definition as
to what constitutes a chair
or i or you and presumably you've used
those in sentences before
with facility well that so can you do
this yeah i i can sort of
vaguely define a chair in some way that
i can most the time recognize a chair
i've
i've tried to define free will and i
just cannot come up with a definition i
poached around a bit as far as i can
figure out nobody else has come up with
a convincing definition either
i mean you certainly have this feeling
in inside yourself
that you can choose what to do but
um you know maybe this feeling is an
illusion
and everything we do is determined by
some laws of physics and we just have
this illusion that
we're choosing what these laws of
physics do
but i don't know i mean i i can't even
define what is meant by
having a feeling that we we can choose
what to do
so you're agnostic on the issue i'm
i think it's even worse than being
agnostic i i'd say i i don't
i'm not saying i don't know what the
answer to the question is i'm saying i
i don't even know what the question
means and i not at all sure it even
makes sense
what about god do you believe in god and
the same problem
uh before we start discussing god i
would like you to define what you mean
by the term
god because there are so many different
definitions
um so you could have a god of your
favorite religion saying it's this
guy who maybe zaps people with
thunderbolts or whatever
or you could say you know god is just a
name
for the underlying essence of the
universe which is sort of
maybe meaningless but you could say in
in that sense god exists because it's
god is just a name for whatever the
explanation of the universe is so there
are
all these different possible definitions
of god and
some of them that you
you could recently say they do exist
some of them you could say
there seems to be very little evidence
for it and others it's just not clear
what the question means so
before discussing this philosophical
question let's first have some
precise definitions you mentioned one
that god is the universe in some way
shape or form
now why is that meaningless well it
because
it's just words it doesn't actually tell
you anything more about the universe
that you didn't already know
um so that there's a whole lot of
questions like this you could say you
know the
the universe is really a simulation or
the universe is um a cellular automaton
or maybe there are lots of parallel
universes
and none of these actually say anything
whatsoever about the universe i mean
that they're all
great plots for comic book stories or
whatever but
you know what what's the difference
between the universe being a cellular
automaton the universe not being a
cellular automaton well i've
there just doesn't seem to be any
difference or what what's the universe
what's the difference between there
being a sort of pantheistic god
underlying everything or they're not
being a pantheistic god well
i've no idea it it just seems to be a
content-free
sentence in your psychology and your
mindset nothing would be changed if you
found out that you were the only
conscious person
or that you were living in a dream i i
don't know how i could tell the
difference between being the only
conscious person or not being the only
conscious person
i mean i assume other people are
conscious just by analogy with myself
but i
i can't imagine any experiment that
could actually prove beyond doubt that
someone else was really conscious rather
than just a
rather than just a computer program
running inside someone's brain
okay again it's this problem of what is
free will i
i can't think of any experiment that can
tell the difference between having free
will and not having free will okay
how about this i imagine that there is
no
experiment that can test whether you
love your wife or your wife loves you
yet i imagine also that the answer to
that matters to you
so in a similar well does it first of
all well it's it's a it's another these
terms it's really hard to
define i mean i'm i think this is this
is another question about my internal
state of mind which as i've noticed in
several of your other questions i a very
hard time figuring out what my internal
state of mind actually is
is that because you're not introspective
do you tend to think about yourself or
do you just tend to think outside
yourself
i i do sometimes think about myself and
the conclusion i tend to come to is that
i have absolutely no idea what is going
on i mean it's
it's it's a problem that i've that
completely baffles me
i mean i have no idea what is going on
in my own mind let alone what is going
on in other people's minds
so do you have any thoughts about
equivocal questions about the
hard problem of consciousness um
you have to remind me which which is the
hard problem i vaguely remember penrose
talking about this but i've
forgotten which is the easy problem
which is the hard problem the easy
problem are the correlates so for
example anger is associated with so and
so part of the brain
and a certain circuit the heart problem
is how is it at all that
consciousness that is experienced can
arise from material only
um yeah this th this is like all these
questions in
douglas hof starters books and again i
have no idea
we have all these experiments like like
suppose you simulate the brain by taking
a
trillion um small computer chips and
wiring them up exactly as the neurons
are wired up in the brain so it behaves
exactly like a human brain is that
conscious
and then you could go a step further and
you could
write a complete description of the
human brain and what it's doing on a
very big piece of paper
and is that piece of paper conscious and
you know if if you you know erase bits
of this piece of paper according to
certain rules they're simulating the
action of the brain
are is you know is is that piece of
paper with all these
things being erased repeatedly conscious
because it's you know in some sense it's
indistinguishable from a human brain
and on the other hand it seems utterly
ridiculous to claim it's conscious
i i have no idea how to resolve this
problem
what are some of your favorite
mathematicians and physicists
alive alive oh um
well i think the the one i like reading
most is probably jp
ser i mean i i don't work in his area
but he's so good at writing that
that i read almost you know i try and
read almost everything he's written
because he's saying
the number theorists explaining well
he's he's one of these really great
mathematicians who
moves around so he's a number theorist
he's also an algebraic geometry he's
also an algebraic apologist and he's
also done quite a few other things i
mean he's he's sort of one of the
closest things we have to a universal
mathematician what about terry tau
um yeah again um um i've been collecting
his books and
and and they're on my big pile of books
i really ought to get around to reading
some day
um and yeah he's
that that's interesting because he
thinks in such a different way from what
i do i mean he's an analyst
and um well again he's not just an
analyst he also does lots of things in
number theory and and so on but
and he's obviously thinking much more in
terms of inequalities and error
estimates and all the other things that
analysts do than i do and so i'm i'd say
much more towards the algebraic side
where i
do equalities and then sort of get a bit
nervous whenever
anybody writes down an inequality sign
what about physicists now uh i don't
really have favorite physicists
um i mean i i enjoy reading richard
feynman but that's
that's that's largely because of his
popular books rather than because of his
physics
[Music]
who else i read you know stephen
weinberg has some rather nice books on
quantum field theory
and yeah i i i don't spend so much time
on physics really
what are your thoughts on ed whitten
have you collaborated with him or met
him
i i i've met him and he's simply
terrifying he he produced these you know
fantastically brilliant papers about one
a month or something and i
i don't know i have no idea how he has
the energy to do this
and you know it's a stream of endless
good ideas that he comes up with i mean
he i mean he he he came up with these
cyborg written in vance and they they
were almost a sort of minor side effect
of something else he was thinking on and
you know they revolutionized some area
in mathematics that
you know he he really
had almost had nothing to do with before
that's you know he was just sort of
revolutionizing the area of mathematics
just as a casual side effect of
something else he was doing
let's get to the monster group what are
some of the applications of the monster
group
to physics they're all intended
are there conjectures um well
there there are some there's been some
speculation i mean
ed whitton for example has some
um speculation about a connection
between the monster and some sort of
gravity theory
and that the mathematics behind the
monsters is quite similar to a lot of
mathematics that turns up in string
theory so you can speculate that there's
a connection but no one has ever found
any sign that the monsters anything to
do with you know real
everyday four-dimensional physics there
are some people who try to build physics
off of the e8
and what has a dimension in eight has an
echo in 24
and then 24 is somehow associated with a
monster
so yeah i'm wondering can one base
physics off of the monster group
um i wouldn't
um i would write that off as a really
crazy idea
i'm not saying it's wrong i'm just
saying it's really crazy
um i mean it'd be really nice if the
monster group did turn up in physics
somewhere but as i said there's there's
no
realistic sign of this yet apart from
the fact that both the monster and
string theory use that you use similar
ideas
for people watching just so you know
professor portraits has a
great youtube series on teaching
graduate level mathematics and i
recommend you check that out do you
enjoy teaching
is it just your connotation it's fun
making these videos except it's
it's also kind of stressful because
i mean it's i hadn't realized just how
many
errors i made in lectures um you know
you're lecturing and
you don't notice anything wrong and then
suddenly
when you put the youtube up people
pointing out all these embarrassingly
stupid
misprints you made and
you know i i i guess i should just feel
relieved that i'm not a you know i
sometimes think well it's
thank goodness i'm not a doctor or a cop
or something because you know if a
doctor or a cop makes a mistake
you know there's someone dead and there
are headlines and committees of inquiry
and
when i make an embarrassing mistake i
get this polite note from a youtube
comment so i
maybe i shouldn't complain too much
about it you mentioned
that innovations coming from outside the
field of academia
for math in particular is rare unlike
the past which was
you gave some examples for matt and
kaylee who were lawyers
and i'm wondering is this still true
today as far as i know
you mentioned one of the reasons is that
it's easier to get a position in
academia
but i don't know if that's true today
well unless you're a postdoc it's very
much true compared to now compared to a
few hundred years ago when there
basically weren't any positions for
mathematicians in academia
maybe one or two in the world the the
other big problem is
all the easy stuff in mathematics and
physics has been done
so people like firma when they started
doing mathematics said that there were
whole loads of things they could do
which well that they were difficult for
the time but nowadays they count as easy
whereas
if someone was starting from outside
trying to do mathematics now it'd be
incredibly difficult because
anything you can think of in less than
several years study someone has already
thought of it so it's it's partly that
there are
i mean i mean people coming from outside
doing something big in mathematics has
become
very rare because it's so difficult to
find
any problem that an outsider can do
what advice do you have for outsiders
who want to contribute to math or at
least study it at the graduate phd level
but they're on their own it's the
pandemic they don't have peers
much like yourself you don't collaborate
so what advice do you have for them
if you really want to contribute
something new you need to find a
relatively new
area in mathematics um
so i mean every now and then that
someone has a new idea that breaks open
a new area
and then you know it's it's like you
know there's this
um dead whale theory you know if you're
at the bottom of an ocean there's
usually nothing to eat but every now and
then there's a dead whale comes down and
everybody goes frantic eating it
and every now and then there's a really
new area in mathematics and if you can
spot one of those and get in on it then
there's a lot to do
a typical example a few years ago with
things like
fractals and chaos became really big
things and there was quite a lot to do
it's very hard to suggest new areas
because if i knew about them then
i'd probably already be working in it or
something um
yeah there's one thing i was thinking of
that
it might be possible to contribute that
none people are not mathematicians might
be able to contribute to and that's
um artificial intelligence
doing mathematics i mean you know
um so google came up with this
artificial intelligence program that
could play go or chess
very well and i'm pretty sure the people
at google programming this were not
expert go or chess players
they they were what they were really
good at was building an artificial
intelligence system and
sooner or later artificial intelligence
is probably going to get good enough to
do serious mathematics
um so that might be one thing to look at
if you're an outsider um you know
get into artificial intelligence doing
mathematics i think there are not so
many
pure mathematicians looking at that now
and
in a few years it might take off quite
suddenly so in some sense
let's say 30 40 years from now the
computers will be better than us at
doing mathematics so why don't you be
the puppet master behind the computer
if you want to help the innovation yeah
yeah exactly
at some point did you ever feel like
math and physics wasn't for you either
because of its difficulty or for some
other reason
um no not really
um it sort of never never seriously
occurred to me to do anything other than
mathematics i mean
maybe when i was six i you know thought
it'd be fun to be a
fighter pilot or something but apart
from that it's
never seriously considered anything
other than mathematics or possibly
computing as an emergency backup
what are your thoughts on the many
worlds interpretation
well like i said it's you have all these
phrases
like you know maybe the maybe there are
many worlds maybe there's a
we're a computer simulation maybe we're
uh cellular automaton that
they don't seem to mean anything um so
what's the difference between a many
worlds interpretation and a non-many
worlds interpretation well there doesn't
seem to be any difference
okay i'm gonna get to some audience
questions from
reddit i think that modern geometry is
overly complicated as in
if you look at john lee's introduction
to smooth manifolds you'll find that it
has
plenty of little lemmas and theorem
theorems that say very little
the content is little but they're
elaborate proofs
and i'm wondering if this inadequacy is
due to basing the foundations of math on
set theory
leading to very cumbersome frameworks
for geometry
do you sometimes feel that there should
be a way to base mathematics
off of some alternate framework some
topological geometric consideration
that's less cumbersome well there have
been
endless attempts to do this i mean what
you have to remember is that
set theory didn't become the well
practical foundations and mathematics
just because someone decreed it
um what happened early in the 20th
century people were trying
dozens and dozens and dozens of
different attempts to have foundations
and mathematics i mean
the principia mathematica of russell and
white's head
lambda calculus um
and um quine or however you pronounce
his name came up with
another foundation of mathematics and
the reason we use set theory because it
was one out as being the most convenient
one and
people are trying all sorts of things
these days based on type theory or
category theory
and again none of them have really taken
over from set theory so
so set theory as sort of one by sort of
evolutionary process
people keep trying to modify things and
taking the fittest one that
that survives best and set theory is the
one that has won out
so when you say set theory is clumsy and
lots of problems to it yes that's true
but the trouble is everything else is
even worse problems
um i figure that when computers start
doing mathematics
that it may be that they won't use set
theory because
some forms of type theory or something a
little bit more computational and set
theory maybe a bit better
um and in fact there there are
about a dozen or so different attempts
to
find a good foundation for computers
doing mathematics and most of them
um don't seem to use set theory directly
but again what we're seeing is an
evolutionary process people are going to
try out
all these different approaches and
probably one of them will turn out to be
better than the others and take over
i find that when i talk to category
theorists they say the foundation should
be category
oh that's nonsense category theory is a
useful bookkeeping device but the idea
that it's the ultimate foundation is
just
silly i mean it's like you know finite
simple group theorists saying the
ultimate foundation should be finite
simple group theory or whatever
um the problem is category is just not a
primitive concept
um you can write down axioms for a
category but there's
you know it's you know i mean maybe you
want to base mathematics on say an
elementary topos which is a special sort
of category
well fine you can develop mathematics
inside an elementary topos that's no
problem
the trouble is this gives you no
explanation for why
the actions for an elementary topper
should be consistent
um set theory at least makes a sort of
gesture about trying to explain why the
axioms of set theory are consistent i
mean
i don't think it's a very successful
explanation but at least they sort of
make a
you know they they they make a sort of
token attempt
um trying to claim the foundations of
mathematics a category theory there's
there's just no attempt to explain why
the axiom should be true or consistent
or whatever
this is a similar question i have always
been interested in seeing whether we
could develop an all-encompassing
framework despite decades of seeing a
proliferation of different set
theories with all sorts of independent
results i know hugh woodland
or hugh wooden has been working on
ultimate l
some ultimate l research program while
others say pluralism is here to stay
people like joel david hampkins
who is a mathematical platonist what are
your thoughts on this subject
do you think mathematicians like hugh
wooden and
peter culner may find success in
developing an ultimate canonical model
of set theory
or would you more closely align yourself
with the multiverse view
of set theory that hampkins advocates
for i think
well my views on this change every month
or every year or so so
the current views is that my impression
is
is very much that there are many
different models of set theory and
there's no
ultimate model um in in some sense as a
consequence of godel's incompleteness
sim there's no
ultimate model of all sets that the best
we can do is have a
hierarchy of increasingly powerful
models or systems of set theory
so you know you can start off with say
zermlow set theory might be you know
somewhere near the bottom and then
above that you can have zermalo frenkel
set there which is a more powerful model
and then you can
start adding in your favorite um
your your favorite large cardinal axioms
and it just doesn't seem to be an
ultimate model
um and i think it's unlikely that it
will be in fact if there was an
ultimate model then you could just you
know
hit it with gerdell's theorem and point
out there's an even bigger model that
proves the consistency of your so-called
ultimate model
um you you may be able to find a sort of
ultimate convenient model that can do
everything we can think of at the moment
um
but i mean in some sense that's what
zermelo frankel set theory is it's
it's i don't think anybody claims that
zermelo franco's set theory is an
ultimate model but it's
it's enough to do almost everything we
need to in mathematics so it's a very
convenient one
you said that your views on this change
month by month or year by year
so what was it before and why did you
change it i don't know i sometimes
thought that
you know you can it can oscillate
between
finitis mathematics where you deny
everything that can't be expressed in
terms of computation and
you can go from there all the way to
platonism where you
claim that there is a single ultimate
universe of all sets
and there are all sorts of intermediate
points and i sort of float up and down
this depending on
i don't know depending on my mood or
what i've been thinking about recently
so recently or currently what do you
think of finite you called it finite
as far as i know it's called
intuitionist logic the computational
model
um that that has a lot going
for it um basically it's especially if
you're trying to do mathematics on a
computer because of course
a computational based foundations of
mathematics are particularly convenient
if you're actually trying to do
computations
um i mean you know computers can't
directly manipulate sets in the way that
they can directly manipulate
integers um the only trouble with the
finitistic foundations and mathematics
is they're very restrictive and it's
it's really hard to do most mathematics
in them i mean
it's sort of what the analogy is like um
you know it's one of these religious
sets i think someone once said it's a
bit like the shakers who
who built really sturdy barns but didn't
have offspring and and fine artist
mathematics is like that it's
it's really solid and
absolutely solid foundation but there's
it's it's difficult to do anything
productive with it
i mean i mean if if you look at any
almost any piece of
mathematics for instance if you look at
say
why is this proof of firma's last
theorem okay fermi's last theorem makes
perfect good sense to a constructive
fine artist mathematician but
trying to encode wires as proof in
finitis terms well it would probably be
possible but it would be a real
nightmare to do i mean it would it would
take years and years of really boring
tedious work even if you could actually
do it
ariane raj asks can people after 40s
learn mathematics up to an advanced
level now let's
break that down i don't believe he's
asking can they research can they
contribute to research
i think this person wants to know can i
learn enough that i can
let's say understand one of your papers
if i'm starting at 40
i'm sure you could if you if you're
willing to spend enough time on it so
you have to remember that when people in
their 20s learning mathematics
as grad students whatever they're
spending you know 8 or 12 hours a day
every day for years learning it and if
you're prepared to put that amount of
time into it in your 40s
my guess would be you probably could the
problem is you know by the time people
are in their 40s they tend to have jobs
and kids and all sorts of other
distractions so
it's very much harder to put in the
amount of time necessary
boris costello wants to know your take
on the unreasonable effectiveness
of mathematics in the natural sciences
this has
really baffled me i mean that what was
my take on it
well that just sums it i mean so the
problem is there's
there seems to be no reason at all why
the universe should make any sense i
mean
you you imagine what people thought
about the way the universe works
you know two or three thousand years ago
you know things just happened for no
reason trees just grew because that's
what trees
did or maybe there was some god making
them grow or something and
we've discovered since then that nearly
everything seems to be
ultimately controlled by mathematics
and i've no idea why or no idea why this
should be true
um you know it's possible you could have
a universe that
that just sort of was like a universe
that sprang from the mind of a fantasy
author where things just worked by magic
for no particular reason but
we seem to be in one where it runs on
mathematics
rajesh v wants to know are you puzzled
by most people's inability to understand
math
or do you see a reason behind it i'm not
puzzled by most people's inability to
understand math what really puzzles me
is the fact that anyone can understand
math at all
i mean from a point of view if you're an
evolutionary psychologist
you can pretty much prove that no human
could possibly do mathematics because
you know think about where we evolved we
were
running around on the probably the
african plains being
chased by leopards or tigers or
something and if you get someone who
you know stops to wander about large
cardinals well
you know 10 minutes later they're going
to be passing through the digestive
system of some large carnivore
i mean the the mathematics gene should
have been wiped out by
um a high evolutionary pressure
so you know what why why do humans get
get interested in mathematics it's
this is what's difficult to explain
what's the longest time you've thought
about a problem before finding a
solution to it
uh
well it's either
i think let me see moonshine conjectures
were probably about
10 years um i might be able to give you
about 40 years and i don't know whether
i've actually solved the problem yet so
somewhere between 10 and 40 years
depending on whether the
problem i'm currently working on works
out or not is the problem you're
currently working on a monumentous one
is it one that people would recognize if
you were to say by name
if i know that you stated my name
everyone would think i'd gone completely
mad so i'm not going to say anything
more about it it's about god isn't it
i said mad i didn't say crazy
what do you think of ramanajan a
self-taught math genius
this is just i'm just overwhelmed by it
because he he did something that
you know i thought would have been
almost impossible that's it that he
managed
by his own unaided efforts to turn
himself into one of the
you know greatest mathematicians i mean
you you look at what he was
growing up in he was he was growing up
in extreme poverty
and i mean even surviving in those
conditions
would have been as much as most people
could do and to
to do this phenomenal mathematics i just
cannot imagine how he did it um
i mean you know i mean ramanujan himself
said that you know how did he get his
mathematical formulas and he said he got
them in dreams from some goddess or
something and
i i can't actually think of it a better
explanation i mean
it's it's it's almost miraculous that he
managed to do this
right some of the formulas are so arcane
and so esoteric
that you wonder how can you come up with
it without deriving them and he would
just
they would just pop into his head and
they would turn out to be true well
i i don't know i i i think i think he
was fudging a bit then i i think it was
um i mean you know some mathematicians
have this
a bit of a desire to keep their methods
to themselves a bit and
maybe romantic was doing that to some
extent
um but i i really don't know i mean i've
looked at his
some of his papers and books and i just
i just cannot imagine how he thought of
them i mean
some of his formulas you can prove by
using techniques that ramanujan didn't
know about i mean it's kind of
notorious that manager never knew
complex analysis
which is a but he know which is a very
powerful method for
evaluating integrals but somehow he he
never seemed to feel the lack of it he
was able to do by
real variable methods what most of us
need complex variable methods to do
so somehow he just got
really really really good at real
variable methods in a way that almost
nobody since has managed to equal
bob bobady says thanks for the q a i'm
just wondering if you plan on continuing
your number theory series
yeah um the if you're talking about my
youtube channel
um well i i'm not really planning to but
i'm not planning not to it's
it's just sort of topics just
turn up at random depending on what i
feel like and what people
vote for and so on so probably if i if i
keep going number theory will probably
continue
i requested to you over email for you to
start a series on quantum field theory
what are the chances of that uh
not all that high because i i had a sort
of bad experience with it
like like i tried to understand it and
[Music]
you know invested a few years and felt
i'd really
it's like really hitting a concrete wall
when you read quantum field theory books
virtually
every one of them tackle the problem
differently
unlike mechanics or quantum mechanics
even
i would be so curious to see how you
tackled it
well that yeah so so when you say
different or
differently i think you you presumably
mean there are lots of different
approaches like you can do it by
operator algebras or by perturbation
theory or by
trying to make sense of infinite
dimensional integrals or by
doing topological quantum field theories
or whatever so so there are
all these different approaches and what
they all have in common is that none of
them really work
um so i was looking at all of them and
couldn't really make pretty much
progress on any of them
so i mean the the the one that people
have
that's been most successful is the
perturbation theory approach i mean this
is sort of what physicists actually use
to calculate numbers that they check in
um
their experiments um but again
you know perturbation theory produces
these divergent infinite series
and to make sense of them you cheat you
just take the first few terms which
makes no mathematical sense
and i was never able to
figure this out so you see an
arbitrariness as to when they choose to
cut off
well
maybe physicists who know more about
this would say it isn't arbitrary but as
far as i can figure out
that there didn't seem to be any very
good reason for stopping at some point
rather than another i mean
i guess you can stop when the terms
start getting bigger again but that's
sort of mathematically very unnatural
ja524309 that's the username says i'm
curious
why you think memorizing proofs is
useless or less useful than doing
calculations
could you elaborate i should say i agree
with some of your other remarks
eg they're not being the best proof
of any particular theorem that was when
you were asked about
the book i was watching a talk by barry
mazur
the other day and he spoke also how
different proofs can sort
of allude to different possible
generalizations of the same problem
which may or may not necessarily
themselves be able which they may not
be able to unify yeah um
sorry that was yeah let me just read the
first part because i believe the
question is got confused by having two
questions right
oh i'm confused i'm confused reading it
okay
i'm curious why you think memorizing
proofs is less useful than doing okay
let's do that let's do that part first
um i think this is one of the things
that probably varies from person to
person so
so people have very different styles for
learning things and maybe for some
people memorizing proofs
is a useful thing i'm just saying for me
personally
i i never found memorizing proofs to be
very useful that's mainly because my
memory isn't as good as some people's i
mean i've i've
noticed that some people have incredible
memories i i mean
you know that they can sort of read a
book and basically recite it back word
for word
so so von neumann for example could do
that and
maybe for people like that that they can
memorize proofs but
for for me at least the i mean i i could
memorize a proof of i put a lot of
effort into it but it would be
you know i mean it's it's there's what
economists call an opportunity cost
my time is actually more productively
spent doing something else because
i i seem to learn i seem to understand
things better by actually doing
calculations with examples so
um so so i i guess my answer only
applies to me and doesn't necessarily
apply to other people
you mentioned learning styles yeah okay
so what are some of the different
learning styles and how does one figure
out their own
the one that fits for them well for me
learning is very very much i have to
my learning style is i as i said i need
to do calculations and i need to
read things over and over again because
i'm rather bad at
learning things other people's learning
styles i
i don't actually know much about because
all i can notice is that they're
obviously different from mine in some
ways
a really obvious one is i'm terrible at
learning languages whereas other people
can
learn languages really easily so they
must be doing something different
do you have a philosophy of mathematics
and if so what is it
philosophy of mathematics well this is
this is like the question about
what the right foundation should be and
as i said my that that there are several
underlying philosophies
so there's finitism where you think
everything should be computation and
platonism where you think everything
exists in some mystical realm and
there's
formalism where it's just a game you
play
with with with rules and
i'd say i i sort of
kind of oscillate between them or maybe
amalgamate them all i mean that
they all have some good points and some
bad points
so i don't really have a single
philosophy i just sort of
um kind of amalgamate all philosophies
and pick and choose whichever is most
convenient at the time
and it seems you know there seems to be
something a little bit off about this
it's like trying to belong to several
different religions all at once
but but somehow for mathematical
philosophies maybe you can get away with
it
what do you mean you pick and choose
which one's useful what would be an
example of one that's useful for you
um well i mean i think the different
philosophy
wouldn't really be useful for actually
doing math research
the different philosophies would be
useful for trying to understand what the
foundations of mathematics and the
universe are
um so if you if you think the universe
should be based on computation then
maybe you try working with a
finitistic computational model of
mathematics
um if you if you're trying to understand
some
deep complicated theorem then
it's it's very difficult to prove these
theorems in a finitistic model so you
may have to sort of switch to a
more platonic model where there is you
know you
you you assume the existence of very
strong constructions like the power set
of a set
i mean it's very difficult developing
things like general topology for example
in the
in a finitistic universe
how does one know by the way this
question is from bag bigger
how does one know when they're on the
right path in finding a solution
i've tried substantial unsolved problems
and i end up making progress
but then i feel like i'm chasing my own
tail this is one of the hardest problems
in research
and if you you know if you could solve
this problem
you you become the world's greatest
mathematician it's sort of like asking
how do you time the stock market
nobody knows how to do it and if you if
you could you'd be really rich
um so so that it's this question of
knowing
what the right solution to a problem is
the right way to solve a problem is and
you know i mean
this is in some sense the hardest part
of research trying to trying to figure
out whether you're on track or not
um i heard a story about that there was
this mathematician called nagata who was
you know half his work was proving these
amazing theorems and half his work was
proven these stunning counter examples
to theorems and
the story i heard was that you know
every morning he would try and prove a
theorem
and every afternoon he would try and
find a counter example so so one or the
other would work out so so
so he had both both bases covered in
some sense he he
he he didn't need to know when he was on
the right track because he was trying
all possible tracks simultaneously
and and just found out which one worked
by trying everything
tahum asks can you explain langlin's
program and does it have any connection
to physics
no yes um langland's program
if you had to say it in one sentence it
would say that
um automorphic forms on groups have
something to do with
representations of galway groups which
sounds like this
obscure technical stuff
but um rather amazingly an awful lot of
problems in mathematics
turn out if you go very deep into them
to to be related to the langlens
program for example um the classic
example of this is wireless as proof of
firma's last theorem was was essentially
using this idea
um does it have anything to do with
physics well
some of the more recent work on
geometric langlands is using ideas from
quantum field theory so
i can give you a definite maybe on that
one
um there are certainly some ideas that
turn up in both langman's program and
physics whether or not there's any more
direct connection
i don't know but it wouldn't surprise me
langland's program seems to
it seems to be one of these things that
turns up almost everywhere if you go
really deeply into something
you mentioned that you're extremely
interested in learning more about it
i've been so for decades and there's
there's just so much to learn
i mean um
i mean that langland's program seems to
be the ultimate black hole for what you
need to learn in order to understand it
like there are there are several very
deep subjects like representation theory
and algebraic geometry which are
themselves notorious for how
how much you have to learn to get into
them and langlen's program
sort of sub sums all of these you need
to know algebraic geometry and
representation theory
and a lot of hard analysis so it's more
or less
it's almost like it's every hard area of
mathematics all combined into one
well you do have a course on
representation theory
and on algebraic geometry so you should
have some
advantage there no these are just
scratching the surface of what you need
to know
the representation theory i've put on is
just finite
groups in characteristic zero which is
the
easiest example it's not quite trivial
but it's it's the really easy part of
representation theory langland's program
the groups become
infinite groups the representations
become infinite dimensional
everything becomes far far more
complicated
just us perths asks how can a person
who's self-studying deal with gaps in
knowledge
when i get stuck on a new concept i'm
often unsure
exactly what it is that's preventing me
from understanding it and i
in other words i don't know what i don't
know well one
one thing you can do these days is is
there are lots of math discussion groups
on things like reddit and you can just
try
asking i mean you may have to poke
around a bit to find the right sort of
math discussion group to answer whatever
level of question you're asking
um some groups i think there's a
there's if you search for math overflow
and math stack exchange these
uh where you can ask questions and
you'll quite often get
serious answers from from mathematicians
about them
okay for the people watching please ask
any further questions because i'm gonna
end this at some point soon but make
sure your question is asked in such a
way that if i read it verbatim it makes
sense because i don't like having to
parse them
in real time just one question at a time
because my short-term memory seems to
getting worse and worse yes just
keep it at the length of one sentence
one short one
14-word sentence okay what have you been
reading recently
let's say non-fiction and fiction
my mind is for some reason completely
blanking out on this
um
um i mean i can give a boring answer of
all the books i was reading for my
youtube videos um
[Music]
and you tend to look at older books at
least you reference them plenty for
example you referenced a book that was
100 years old
where the calculation where the graphics
look like it's modern graphic
but it was oh yeah yeah
that yeah that's that's that that book
is absolutely fantastic because it's
it's got all
you know it's written in the days before
computers and the graphics there just
blow away most of the graphics people
produce by computer these days somehow
their pictures have a sort of soul in
them whereas if you if you just get a
computer to draw a graph of
function it's just you know the is
it's just not there yeah yeah the heart
isn't in it
exactly i mean that the you know known
as
known as sweated blood to do the picture
and you're just not interested
and i can't imagine how they did it i
mean that they're just
pages and pages of numerical data they
must have all done by hand and that
there are
pages and pages of graphs that must have
been painstakingly drawn and calculated
i mean that the amount of effort they
put into that is just extraordinary
how are you finding youtube by the way i
imagine it's new for you
um it's it's interesting and very
stressful as
i said i get really really bugged out by
making mistakes on my videos
it's it's just it's just so embarrassing
having these
well um what i was thinking is um
what it reminds me of you you know you
get these books um written
you know that the million stupidest
things ever said by professor watts
by by president watts's name and things
like that
i suddenly have an awful lot more
sympathy for president watts's name who
who blurts out something stupid whenever
he opens his mouth because i've noticed
in my youtube videos i'm continually
making really really dumb mistakes
i mean it seems to be almost impossible
not to you
you can prepare and check everything and
it doesn't matter when you're actually
talking the stress
causes you to say really dumb things
you get stressed out when you're making
your youtube videos it's somehow very
yeah yeah it's it's very stressful and
when you're stressed your mind just
closes down and you
you make the dumbest mistakes and you
get to the end of the video and you
wonder how you could have said something
so stupid what is it about it that you
like so you just mentioned a negative
aspect
well it gives me something to do i mean
as i said research
consists most of the time of getting
nowhere and if you're making youtube
videos you're at least doing something
and
um i was rather surprised people
actually seem to like watching
math lectures on youtube i mean yeah i
mean i i started putting these videos
because they were my
you know lectures for courses i supposed
to be teaching and i had to
make some videos for them and
i i sort of didn't really occur to me
that people would actually watch them
for fun because i i can't stand watching
lectures
um so but other people obviously learn
differently
how much time do you spend thinking
about your own particular background on
knowledge and skills and relating it to
previous knowledge
versus spending time thinking without
relating
uh gosh that's a abstract question i'm
not quite sure
um i i would
say i'll try and answer it i would say
that nearly everything i do i'm trying
to relate it to other things
other things i know i mean a lot of
what research consists of is making
unexpected
connections between things so so if
you're
if you're working a completely new area
that has no connections to anything you
know in the past
it's going to be really really difficult
because it's going to take a lot of time
to build up
enough knowledge to start making
connections so so you really want to be
relating everything you do to
hopefully to something you've done
earlier
i mean you you're trying to build up a
big in connected web not have a lot of
series of discrete
domains of information that have nothing
to do with each other
neon dagger asks math people often talk
about being drawn
in by a wow subject that is hidden from
them earlier on
is it important to wow students to draw
them into math
um if you're trying to encourage people
to do mathematics this would be one way
of doing it
but it's again one of these things where
different people have different
approaches that some people are drawn in
by this
wow thing and others have drawn in
because they
the the they're just in they
they're just like working steadily for
um
your your hang on your your screen has
gone very weird
oh okay one second where we go there we
go there we go
do you remember what you were saying as
i said i'm under stress which makes my
short term memory even worse than usual
do you feel stressed being interviewed
right now
very much so i mean i i've noticed i've
noticed this that
i'm having great difficulty thinking
about
questions that people ask um i have the
same phenomenon in lectures people ask
me a question in a lecture and i've
no idea what the answer is and then i
get out of the lecture and it's
it's completely obvious so somehow
yeah yeah being interviewed or talking
whatever the
the high parts of my brain simply close
down
how often are you interviewed um
i think well
not not very um i mean there's seen here
one or two people
asking me for you know their
undergraduates doing projects where they
have to interview a professor or
something so
i've had maybe two or three um
interviews yours
your screen has gone weird again okay
okay let me just switch cameras then
completely
i have a feeling it's just overheating
yeah i was looking just so you know i
was looking for interviews of you
other people doing podcasts with you and
i couldn't find any
okay what's up with goldbach's
conjecture and why is it hard to crack
i don't really know why it's hard to
crack um
it's people have got very close i think
there was a
um i think
this isn't my area so i may have
misremembered i think there's a chinese
mathematician maybe
chen or something who who managed to get
very close so so goldback's conjecture
says that
um um every uh
which every even number is the sum of
two primes and you can get quite close
to that that
with a lot of work you can prove that
every even number is the sum of a prime
and a product of two primes
and for some reason there's some
horrible obstruction to going any
further than that
and i've never managed to understand
what the instruction is um i think terry
tau
who you mentioned i i once saw a
discussion by him of what this
obstruction is so
he might be the better person to ask um
and again
you can we we can prove that every odd
number is the sum of three primes
so we've got three primes instead of two
primes so we've got very close to it but
again there seems to be this weird
obstruction to pushing that last little
little step um
so as i said it's not my area so i don't
know exactly what this obstruction
is elham romanti
or rahami asks what advice do you have
for someone in their 20s trying to learn
math
um i know variations on this question
i've been asked before already
well go for it i mean i mean it it
depends very much on how much time you
can spare to put into it i mean people
in their 20s are quite often trying to
have their career starting up so may not
actually have a whole lot of spare time
um um
so i'm probably just repeating the
answer i gave earlier but
my advice would be to find something
you're really interested in and
my usual suggestion for that is
something like modular forms which is
the but that that's the area i found
particularly striking
i just wanted to conclude by saying
thank you i appreciate you being
generous with your time
i watch your videos i gain from them and
i'm pretty sure
plenty of the audience from this channel
will gain from it as well
yeah well i i i'm sort of
i i think having interviews like this is
really good practice for me since i'm
as you know as i show you observed i'm
rather nervous not very good at them
so well just so you know i'm extremely
nervous as well and partly one of the
reasons i have to go urinate is because
i urinate when i'm nervous
yeah i'm thinking how cut how calm and
professional you looked no i'm
absolutely
thank you i'm absolutely not
professional i appreciate that you would
even give me a modicum of that
i'm more i i'm much
i'm extremely introverted and i have
social anxiety it's just that i've
had to trade myself to overcome it to
some degree is everybody
faking it or there's some people who are
really extroverts
oh there are plenty of people who are
extroverts just so you know it was
somewhat ill-advised on my part to
speak to you because usually
i have i ask a professor can i speak
with you
six to eight weeks from now and then
they'll say yes or no and then i have
six to eight weeks to look up
their corpus of work and make notes and
and ask them somewhat
challenging questions or technical
questions for
furthering my understanding basically
trying to get in their head not trying
to disprove or
have a contentious interview at all just
trying to understand
and for this one i had i messaged you on
monday i believe you said yes on tuesday
and then i had one full day only this
week
to go through your entire work and i
could barely get through the
i can barely get through the overview of
the proof for the monstrous moonshine
conjecture i think you're way ahead of
most people on that
the surprise is not that it's hard to
understand the surprises that we can
understand it at all
i'm much more algebraic far more
algebraic than i am geometric and i
dislike when people
show group theory at first with the
rubik's cuber with the triangle
because to me i'm just thinking there
are far more symmetries than what you've
just
shown so someone will say the triangle
has six it may not may have eight i
don't know but whatever then i'm
thinking yeah but isn't there also the
symmetry of
let's say you invert the thickness of
the line and then bring it back so is
that not a symmetry
or is there not a symmetry of inverting
the colors and then bringing that like
why are you choosing
just just show me the axioms
algebraically i understand that
yeah well yeah
um yeah but i think i think that
it's a usual problem that you you can't
give a presentation of group theory that
satisfies everybody because people's
learning styles are so different some
want to see the axioms
some want to see examples and so on were
the questions okay
yeah except the ones where i
when i kind of got stressed out and
couldn't think what to say i mean
you know sometimes my i think there's
one weird one you're asking what what i
had been reading recently my brain just
completely froze
um yeah i find that happens for me as
well
you know no no no i think it i was
actually thinking about that
i'd read somewhere where where you know
someone was saying well that they'd ask
people what they're reading been reading
recently and
and some people were unable to answer
with a single book
as an example of how illiterate people
weren't i think to myself well
exactly the same is happening with me i
just can't think of anything i've
written in the part anything i've read
in the past day
i just couldn't think of anything at all
even though i've looked at several books
you know just hoping i didn't say
anything that's going to get me
condemned on the internet you know there
seem to be
too many cases of people who
inadvertently say something harmless
which turns out to be a code word for
some horrible crime see many
mathematicians physicists too
they have a difficult time with
answering questions that have to do with
that are ambiguous and yeah well me too
i mean you know whenever there was a
freezing up every now and then with uh
with with one of these
more more general questions right and i
would freeze up too
but the difference between me is that i
first
i have an artistic side that's the
filmmaking side that's the stand-up
comedy side
so in a sense that's almost like you're
you deal with ambiguity
as your regular male you so for me
i don't have too much of a problem with
it and it and i find that much of the
i don't know if you'll agree with this
but i've heard this said that much of
the pr much of the solution comes from
specifying the problem
and so i wonder how much of let's say
is an ant conscious or what is
consciousness and so on so on
how much of it is the solution
is just well how do we define it
properly
yeah well and this this seems to be the
cause of half the problems in philosophy
there they're arguing about something
that simply hasn't been properly defined
um possibly you could say the same about
religion
too
yeah and then some will even say that
par actually it's the opposite
the problem in religion is that people
are trying to define it and it should be
left
implicit possibly yes i mean
it's like me backing out of your
question about
god by saying i didn't know how it was
defined
that's everyone that's every well that's
not everyone but that's most
mathematicians most physicists
and that would be me prior to two years
ago yeah so
well mathematicians actually trained to
have things well defined before you
start discussing them of course
um but but
sorry i wanted to speculate around that
because i wonder how much of it is
it's not that they don't like that it's
somewhat meaningless quote unquote
but that because it's meaningless
they're afraid that what they will say
will then be used against them
in some fool like oh you're imbecilic
for saying so and so
and it's more about the fear of
commenting
on what's vague and saying something
foolish than it is about commenting on
it at all and the reason why i say that
is because in our everyday life like i
mentioned to you we do use the word game
and chair and i
but those are actually ill-defined like
what is a chair maybe it's something to
sit on but then you get stumps
and then but what is i the more you look
at i what
what defines i and you you know there's
various well i i'd say everything is
ill-defined but but some things are more
ill-defined than others so
so chair i will normally know whether
something is a chair or not
um whereas something like god i just no
idea
um it's it's it's much i mean chair and
god may both be ill-defined but but
but but god is a lot more ill-defined
than chair
before we were talking about ramanujan
and you mentioned that when he
said that he got his ideas from his
prayers his visions meditations and so
on that probably he didn't he had a
secret mechanism
that he wasn't revealing and i'm curious
do you
have a secret technique to mathematics
that you don't reveal
uh no um and and i i don't know about
romantic either i'm just sort of
guessing that that's maybe he was
giving an answer to a slightly silly
question i mean it's it's
as i said it's just very difficult to
analyze your own mind and figure out
where ideas are coming from
what do you think would be the
implications that fermanagh did indeed
get his formulas inexplicably from his
visions and so on from a goddess or god
well i think that would just be his
explanation of explain what's going on
in his subconscious brain
i mean you here we call it subconscious
other cultures might call it
um a vision from a goddess i mean
but they're both ways of saying we have
no idea what's going on
you mentioned before that modular forms
are a field that you find to be the most
fascinating or provocative or
stimulating i don't recall which one of
those adjectives you used but
why is that the case um
well so so what modular forms do
is is they they they seem to turn up in
all sorts of areas of mathematics that
that
appear to have nothing to do with
modular forms
um obvious one i i used quite a lot was
they turn up in the theory of the
monster simple group and
simple groups seem to have nothing to do
with them um
marina via kovska um used them to
solve the sphere packing problem in high
dimensions and again that has
no obvious relation to modular forms
andrew wiles used them to
prove fermat's last theorem which
there's no obvious reason why they
should turn up so
they're turning up and completely
unexpectedly in all these
completely separate mathematical areas
and whenever they turn up
all these utterly bizarre coincidences
start happening
i mean in order for modular forms to
solve a problem you need a whole chain
of bizarre numerical coincidences and
these numerical bizarre coincidences
often seem to happen um so
you know that there's there's something
very weird going on
um as to why modular forms turn up
in all these places i just have no idea
it's just one of these bizarre mysteries
is one of those connections those
coincidences the one nine six
eight eight three yeah yeah yeah exactly
so there's this
that that's a typical example of this
bizarre numerical coincidence you
you take a representation of the monster
group and it happens to be
almost the same as a coefficient of the
elliptic modular function
okay now i'm going to read to you a
thought from another mathematician i
recall you saying that you believe
mathematics is discovered
and he says it's invented and i don't
know which mathematician this is so
don't worry
this is an anonymous mathematician he
says mathematics is created because it's
a language used by humans so that we can
understand and make sense of the world
around us
for mathematics to be discovered you
would assume
that the way humans perceive the world
is absolute truth and in
some way establish humans as the
universal standard
of everything i might be rambling here
but i get the feeling that if you choose
to see mathematics
as something that was discovered by
mankind you are taking a human-centric
and deterministic view on the universe
we only created it to make sense of
things
just like we created the spoken word to
communicate so what are your thoughts on
that
well whoever said that is indeed
rambling as he suspects
um the point about mathematics is
suppose there's a
another civilization on say alpha
century
and they will have the same mathematics
that we do i mean that
obviously they won't use the same
notation or terminology in the same way
that
you know english and french people do
the same mathematics but they do it in a
different language so they will
they will have the same mathematical
theorems
expressed in their own weird language
and they will have found the monster
simple group and they will have found
modular forms and they will have found
everything else
so it's not a human centric way of
viewing the world it's a universal way
of viewing the world
i mean at least that's why i think maybe
it's me who's rambling but
um i i would say it's disgus it's it's
discovered not invented because any
other advanced civilization will have an
equivalent mathematics
do you think that we'd share an idea of
what the few key theorems are
or important theorem
the book it it it's it's a very
speculative question that
this is in some sense meaningless but in
spite of that i will say yes i i would
guess that other advanced civilizations
will on the whole
share the same key theories maybe not
exactly but
um let me be more explicit as to what i
mean
let me be more clear what i meant was
that they would have the same idea as
that
this theorem is a key theorem not that
they would share the same theorems it
might just be one line as a lemma but we
consider it to be a holy grail
and they would also consider it to be
something of i think there'd be a a lot
of overlap i mean i mean even between
different
i mean that there are different
mathematical um
i mean before the world sort of became
unified there were dif
different mathematical um cultures like
the
greeks and indians and japanese all had
slightly different approaches to
mathematics and they
they weren't exactly the same on what
they agreed were the
central theorems or approaches of the
subject but there was there was a lot of
overlap
yeah recall someone's estimation for pi
was four
i don't recall which time uh spatial
location
yes there'd been some very weird
estimates for pi
okay so tori ko says what does he enjoy
or find meaningful about math
uh
well i i like it because because it's
it's really describing how the universe
works in some very fundamental way i
mean
um as i think i mentioned earlier the
universe seems to be
running on mathematics in some very deep
sense that
you know physics like the standard model
or general relativity
is is really just an application of
mathematics
so when you're discovering something new
in mathematics you can think of it as
being discovering something new about
the way the universe is working
so to me when you say that if i didn't
have any context as to who you were i
would have thought you were either a
theoretical physicist or a physicist
in some capacity why is it do you think
that
math somehow has a more direct access to
the
mechanics of the universe than physics
no i mean
mathematics has access to the way the
universe works
through theoretical physics i mean
theoretical physics is the interface
between mathematics and the
actual physical world in some sense i
mean not
not all mathematics seems to have a
direct relation to the physical world i
mean that no one's found the monster
simple group in in
in in in our four-dimensional universe
yet but um
there's there's a lot of overlap i mean
um it's it's quite
hard to find an area of mathematics
which has nothing whatsoever to do with
the physical world
what type of mathematician would you
consider yourself a pure mathematician
if you have to divide mathematicians up
like that then i guess i
count as pure rather than rather than
applied or a physicist
i mean i as i said i i sort of tried
doing theoretical physics a bit and that
didn't work out so well
so um is that the only reason why you
abandoned theoretical physics in favor
of pure mathematics because
you just had a difficult time or is that
something that seems to be a perfectly
good reason for abandoning something
um yeah harris chandra apparently did
the same he started off as a theoretical
physicist and switched to mathematics
because
he he found it too difficult
terry co torical the same person says
what does he think about biology
psychology philosophy
do you think that you would gain as much
of a sense of
understanding by exploring those fields
um well again i have the caveat that i
don't actually know a lot about these
fields
um biology i tried reading some biology
textbooks and they're incredibly
scary and you read a biology book on the
way that a cell works for example and
it's perfectly obvious that a cell can't
possibly work in the way it describes
it's just so
complicated that that um
the way cells work is so complicated and
bizarre it's very hard to believe to
exist
i'm sort of worried that if i if i read
a biology book
you know the universe will suddenly
catch up with this and i'll drop
dead so i think biology is a bit
dangerous to study because it seems so
so incredible also just so much of it
i mean i i just hadn't quite dawned on
me and just how horrifically complicated
cells are timber finn says
is nature fundamentally mathematical or
something else now i know you touched on
this but
again for timber finn well
depends what you mean by fundamentally
um i would say if you go
deep enough into anything you eventually
get to mathematics i mean you
you might start with you know trying to
understand nature via biology and if you
look really
deep into biology you find it's really
biochemistry
and if you're trying to work out how all
these biochemical molecules work you
discover it's really quantum mechanics
which is physics and if you look at how
physics works you suddenly find you're
down to mathematics
so mathematics is sort of at the core of
everything if you go deep enough
bernardo fitzpatrick asks i would like
to know does the professor
know of italian mathematician dr olivia
carmelo
and if so what does he think of her use
of alexander garthande
tawpos's as a unifying theory in
mathematics
and her interpretation of tapas's or
topoi as bridges
in order to facilitate this unification
well i i
don't don't remember the name off-hand
but toplesses have indeed been used as a
um unifying thing in mathematics so
topos is this
construction that alexander grothenbeck
came up with
and it was shortly afterwards realized
by law vera i think that
toppos was really a sort of almost a
sort of
intuitionistic model of set theory or or
a weak version of set theory
so you can in fact do most mathematics
inside
a suitable topos and in fact this is
this is almost one theme of growth index
algebraic geometry that anything you can
do
in mathematics you should try and do in
an arbitrary topos and that that gives
you a sort of
way of generalizing lots of theorems
does he have an opinion on grothen dick
um i'm just overwhelmed by him i mean i
i just
i mean that there are a lot of great
mathematicians i sort of think
well you know i i could have proved that
guy's theorem if i'd just been a bit
smarter or worked a bit harder and then
there are
other mathematicians i look at their
work and i realize there's just
no way i could possibly have done that
no matter how hard i worked and
you know growth and dick's one of them
and you know there are a few others like
john thompson's work on finite groups i
could just never have done and
andrew wiles's work on firma's last him
i just couldn't possibly have done so
so he's one of the ones who just i have
to admit they're just
way out of reach of anything i could
ever have done have you met wiles
very briefly once or twice
okay many people this comes from per
peridot many people decide that they're
more analytical than algebraic or vice
versa
can he expound on a bit on why he
personally finds inequalities
unappealing as opposed to equalities
this goes back to our
previous conversation they're not
unappealing i like
inequalities it's just that you know i
just don't
what's the word um they're too messy i
just haven't got them
completely internalized i i i don't have
a good feeling for them
um the reason for this i i don't know i
think i just
it's probably just a matter of practice
i spent a lot more time working
thinking about algebra and equalities
and so on and
presumably if i'd spend all that time
thinking about inequalities i would
be the other way around i mean i i think
the difference between
mathematicians who are more algebra and
mathematicians who are more analysis
is is is very much what they spent most
of their time practicing
and the last one is from the same person
peridot he says for the abc conjecture
question
can you please allow him to be as super
detailed as he's as he possibly can be
and if he says he doesn't know much
about it ask him what why he thinks it
hasn't triggered his curiosity i'm
assuming there was a previous abc
conjecture question but i can only
conjecture
as to what that conjecture question was
about so let's say
his last sentence says i am consistently
curious about the process of how
mathematicians decide what is and isn't
worth their time
from a mathematical perspective so i
assume he's wondering why haven't you
tackled the abc conjecture and why do
you choose this topic
rather than this one well i don't have
your interest i haven't tackled the abc
conjecture because it's just too
difficult i mean you you have to
select problems that there's some hope
of making progress
in um if you're asking about my opinions
of machu zuki's work well
i just have no idea i i think i said
earlier i
tried to understand it for a few hours
and it was became obvious to me that it
would take me
many years of study to get a vague idea
of what was going on
um so yeah yeah so so mochizuki's
another one of these guys
who look at his work and there's just
no way i would have been able to to do
that i mean i
i i mean it's a bit controversial about
whether it's right or wrong at the
moment of course but
you know whether it's right or wrong
it's still an an incredible
uh mochizuki's work is still an
incredible achievement
and how do you decide what's worth your
time and what's not from a mathematical
perspective
um if it works it's worth my time and if
it doesn't work it's not worth my time
you you you can't tell in advance you
just have to
if there's a problem or area you start
working on it
and sometimes it just doesn't seem to be
working out and sometimes it does
and deciding what is worth your time is
actually one of the hardest problems in
mathematics because
you you know you you may have spent
several months working on a problem
maybe you're just about to make a
breakthrough and if you only spent
another week on it then you would crack
it
but you can't tell maybe you know
maybe it's a week away from being
cracked maybe you could spend another 10
years on it without getting anywhere
and if you could tell which that this
would make research so much easier
so it's really one of the biggest
problems in research is is figuring out
um which
which approaches are likely to work
how many weeks or months do you usually
give on a problem before you decide it's
solvable or not
by you well i never really give up on
problems
what what what you do is you you work on
problems for a bit and then you
get a bit depressed because you're
getting nowhere and then you put it
aside but
always come back to it later after a few
months or years when
when you i mean what generally happens
is i i i forget
why my approach didn't work and and a
few years later i think oh why doesn't
this approach work and i try it again
and then
then i discover why it doesn't work
again but but every now and then you
you you make a little bit of extra
progress and
sometimes after coming back to the
problem dozen
times you finally managed to solve it
and there are plenty of other problems
i've come back to many times
and that i'm still stuck on them how
come you forgot
that you tried a certain technique and
it didn't work because i would imagine
you take notes
and you would have to take notes taking
notes i mean
it requires being organized i'm i i i'm
very bad at keeping notes of what i do
i mean i mean scrapbooks of your work no
well i tried keeping a scrapbook of some
of my work and i and i looked at it a
couple of years later it was completely
illegible and i couldn't figure out what
on earth i was talking about because i'd
been too lazy to write up proper notes
and yeah and it may not be a bad idea to
sort of forget what the problem was and
come back to it because sometimes when
you come back to it you suddenly realize
that the
thing you were stuck on it wasn't really
valid and there's a way around it
of course most of the time it was valid
but whatever
you know i had a note and it's just a
bullet point it said no ghost theorem
and it
reminded me i wanted to ask you if you
can explain to the audience what the no
ghost theorem is in string theory and
then its connection to the
moonshine conjecture um and you're
allowed to go into technical detail if
you feel like the audience well they're
gonna lose you or even me then that's
fine
this i could probably explain if you
gave me a semester course
um but here goes first of all the name
no ghost thing was a sort of
pun or word play so um in in theoretical
physics there are things called no
go theorems which mean something doesn't
work i mean you
you can't there are various no go hidden
variable themes the no ghost theorists
will sort of play on words
and what a ghost is
in string theory is a name for a
negative norm vector in a hilbert space
and this is extremely disturbing because
hilbert spaces aren't allowed to have
negative norm vectors so if you've got a
negative
norm vector that that rather messes
everything up
and so in order to get quantum mechanics
working you've got to make sure there
are no negative norm vectors in other
words there are no ghosts because
negative norm vectors are called ghosts
so when you take a string and try and
quantize it
you find you've got this big space and
sometimes it has negative normal vectors
in which is really tiresome
and the no ghost theorem proof by i
think it was brower and
goddard and thorne says that if the
string happens to be living in 26
dimensions
then everything is nice and you you
don't get any ghosts
and if it's in 27 dimensions you do get
ghosts and it's
really bizarre this this number 26 turns
up i mean
you you can imagine something special
happening in two dimensions or maybe
three dimensions but
26 dimensions is just ridiculous
so um that that that's why string theory
works in 26 dimensions is because this
there's no ghost theorem and then you
you get super string theory whether
where the critical dimension is 10
rather than 26
and that's still a bit tiresome because
we want to bring it down to four
dimensions
and there are various ways you can try
and get it down to four dimensions but
none of them seems to be totally
satisfactory yet
um and 26 dimensions is really nice
because it ties up with the monster and
the leech lattice
so the leech lattices lives in 24
dimensions
and it turns out that if you've got the
leech lattice there's a very natural
construction
you you sort of embedded in laurentian
space and that involves adding
two to the dimension so the
the 26 dimensions of the no ghost theme
and string theory is
is very close related to the 24
dimensions that the leech lattice lives
in
and the leech lattice is connected to
the monster yeah so
so actually that's another these bizarre
coincidences that i mentioned that
always appears whenever modular
functions and forms turn up because the
the the modular forms are working
doing very special things in 24
dimensions
why is it that in 26 dimensions there's
no ghosts but
there are other flavors of string theory
so do they have ghosts in other
dimensions
yeah yeah so so 26 dimensions is what
happens if you take the simplest
possible version of
string theory and as you say there are
lots of other flavors in string theorem
these tend to have different critical
dimensions so that the next simplest is
super strings and
ten dimensions and you you can sort of
fudge around a bit and find
things going on in 18 or 14 or
six dimensions but the the these are all
getting a bit more complicated
26 is the is the simplest case and
lower dimensions get more and more
complicated
are there higher dimensions than 26 or
is it just prove that that's the kind of
anyone
has managed for the ghosts i mean 26
seems to be an upper bound for all this
nice stuff going on
as far as anyone can tell okay man so
what's your plans
for next where can people find out more
about you where can people find a map
more about me
um if i ever find out i'll i'll close it
down um
i don't know wikipedia maybe i don't
know your youtube page i'll link it in
the description
yeah yeah what's next for you
what's next to me i'm trying to get this
problem that i've been working on a long
time to see if it either works or
doesn't
and this well i hope it will be
sold soon but i've been in this position
of thinking i've solved at least a dozen
times in the past and every single time
it's failed so
i don't know professor thank you so much
this has been a pleasure
oh yeah well thanks for the interview
it's been a instructive experience
and i hope you're going to edit out all
the most embarrassing things i've said
um it's actually only going to be a
compilation of the embarrassing things
you've said
yes i should have yeah it's it's like
when you have a newspaper
interview you you say one dumb thing in
it and that's the one thing that gets
published by the newspaper
you